with tens of thousands of videos were
destroyed by today's Universal Studios
fire the 2008 fire on Universal Studios
famed backlot was deemed a tragedy by
movie lovers it destroyed the King Kong
attraction and the Back to the Future
set but this week we learned the fire
may have destroyed a staggering swath of
music history according to an article in
The New York Times Magazine the fire
consumed a vault containing the
irreplaceable master recordings of an
estimated half-million songs a universal
document uncovered by The Times reads
lost in the fire was undoubtedly a huge
musical heritage the artists affected by
the reported losses are a who's who of
music history Ella Fitzgerald Buddy
Holly Chuck Berry Loretta Lynn Elton
John
[Music]
tom petty's Janet Jackson Guns and Roses
[Music]
Tupac Shakur and REM
just to name a few we all we were still
going back to the archives we always
want to search we always want to go to
history and now we can't do anymore
we can't find the outtakes we can't do
remixes it's really a sad day the
article alleges Universal executives
downplayed the losses after the fire but
universal music disputes the report
saying it contains numerous inaccuracies
and the fire never affected the
availability of the commercially
released music nor impacted artists
compensation yes but it's a copy it's
like seeing an old 16 millimeter copy of
a forties movie very different from
something we stored in 35 millimeter
many of the artists reportedly affected
are still unsure whether their
recordings are gone forever
Rosanna cash tweeted Universal owns my
Master's back to 1996 I'm afraid to ask
roots drummer Questlove pointed to the
article as reason for why two of the
band's early albums won't get a reissue
and Nirvana founding member Chris
Novoselic had this response when asked
about the state of the master recording
for the band's breakthrough album
Nevermind I think they are gone forever
this is just this is really
heartbreaking for so many musicians the
original master recordings of course
have all that original information as
well as notes very often that were made
at the time of the recording
conversation yeah you know discussions
about tracks and way things were so that
may be gone forever - it's it's it's our
break